Why did we let them escape? The
elephant will take their place.
[Music]
What should I do? I have no choice but to withstand the enemy's attack with a good result.
Even if it's just a few mistakes, I
might be able to save them, but
I can't help the injured.  I can't do it
[Music]
Is there a way to stop me?
Is there a product that can buy me time and get in the way?
Damn it, wait a minute, if I
use this,
thank you. I
can use that product. What's the
plan?  I don't
really understand, but I'll
leave it at that.Next, I'll buy additional functions and
change the form.Eh
[Music] If
it's rounded up, it might be misunderstood as if my personality is too harsh.You
should accept this as well.  So far, the
good question starts from here. How can I make her
understand? Insert an effect.
Insert an effect. Insert an effect. I'm
disappointed that there are so many. Insert an effect. Insert an effect.
What do you mean by this? It's
not enough to explain anything. But other than this, there's nothing
I can do about it.
That's not true.
Lately, I'm sure you've been desperately trying to tell me something.
Trust me.  I'm trying to read it somehow.
Just because Lavis believed me this much, I'm
not going to put any effect into this anymore.
[Music] I'm not going to commit
suicide with you guys who won't reveal my name.
[Applause]
What could
it be? It's about to
explode! My eyes
hurt. This is a phenomenon that has become famous on video posting sites. When you
put a certain kind of candy in a cola, the contents suddenly
squirt out. Well, you put this candy in it.
It's okay.
Welcome
[Music]